i wanted to ask a little bit
about working with austin again because
i assume he had
something to do with getting you
involved in this project he did have
something to do with getting me involved
i i don't know
uh how it would have shaken out maybe if
he wasn't but
um i'm glad that it worked out for me
because uh
austin when we were filming the pilot
actually it's always extraordinary
playlist we were hanging out
and he was telling me about this awesome
superhero movie about princes and
princesses and
he's just such an incredibly talented
writer who does so many different kinds
of genres so i wasn't surprised
but i know that whenever austin's
involved with something it's going to
have a ton of heart as well
so you know i did the typical
opportunistic actor thing where i just
said like is there a part for me and he
of course went
there actually is and we thought i
thought we'd
leave it at that i think he might have
mentioned it and then
disney plus and adam astro and zanda
vine and all the powers that be
kind of went through their process and
then a few months later
honestly after i've kind of forgotten
about it i got the call
and then was like on a plane in three
days to toronto to get ready
i love hearing how it all comes together
and especially when that gives me
an excuse to name drop zoe's
extraordinary playlist which is getting
a lot of love right now
but still not nearly as much as it
deserves i
appreciate you saying that um we do not
feel
like we're shortchanged in any way uh we
just think
that we are in on a very special thing
that we know if we just keep doing
what we've been doing people will take
note and sometimes these shows just take
a minute
um but um look we're getting plenty of
praise i mean
mandy moore won an emmy yesterday like i
mean we're not we're not the little
engine that could
we're just we know that we can even
reach more people and
we're confident that it will oh i'm
doing my part to make sure that that
happens thank you so with this ensemble
here
you are kind of the old pro on a set
with a whole bunch of
young actors who not all of them but
some of them this is their first
big movie so of all of the movies you've
worked on over your career
who is an actor that you worked opposite
that makes you say now you know
i have to do this on set for them when
they're first starting out
uh this is actually a random one um but
the first person that comes to my mind
is hugh laurie
i did one of the later episodes of house
and it's just one of those moments where
i was playing a sick patient
and you know you'd expect him to be
just a little bit like i'd look i've
done this for 300 people
you know what i mean and and so this
isn't it doesn't mean as much to him as
it did to me
but he went above and beyond to not only
make me feel comfortable
but to give me everything he could every
ounce in fiber of his being
when it was on my close-up when we were
doing our actual intense we had kind of
a fight
thing that we had um i remember going in
the makeup and hair trailer with him he
was clipping his nails because he wanted
to make sure he didn't
scratch me in any of the moments just
like one of those people that
was very inspirational because when you
are the number one person on a set
you do have the opportunity and ability
to set the tone
and um for that reason i only did one
episode but i had nothing but great
things to say and you could see the
reflection of the crew and i really
think that like
that was some really incredible
leadership and i i try to
just be an open vessel when i'm on set
as well
and it was very interesting this time
around being the uh old
guy the the elder statesman um
but uh but but it was actually you know
interesting certain little technical
things that i took for granted that
um some of the kids would ask me you
know about and
and i couldn't believe i had all this
information it kind of was
a reflective moment for me to be like i
guess i have been doing this for upwards
of 15 years like that's pretty wild
realistically i feel like it was just
yesterday i saw you in a movie where you
were playing like i don't know a college
student or something
yeah yeah but you know what i'm glad to
graduate college and uh be a ta
so i also have to ask you about a
certain something you posted on your
twitter account because i kind of love
this possibility hercules have you heard
anything about the song you did
you know what that wasn't as planned as
it seems
i actually during the beginning of
quarantine especially
was playing so much piano my childhood
piano that i got shipped out to la
and i was just going through all the
catalogs and i was laying down a lot and
posting a lot
and also not posting a lot so that was
something that i actually
just had on my camera roll that i only
sent to my family uh because my mom
loves when i just sing in the rafters
and um and then so when i saw that i was
like oh i actually conveniently have
this and so people are like skylar aston
auditions for hercules the thing is
if i was auditioning for the role of
hercules i would act it more
i probably wouldn't be playing my own
piano and i probably wouldn't choose the
michael bolton key which is
literally in the sky um i think the
in the key that roger bart sings it in
the movie it's a lot lower more
manageable
and uh a a little bit more of an i want
song
so when the time comes if the time comes
i'm ready to train i'm ready to prepare
and i'm ready to give everything i can
to hercules if possible if not hercules
i might suggest looking at robin hood
too
i feel like you i don't know i still
can't picture what exactly is going to
happen with that one but i still feel
like
your skill set would very well suit that
role talk to
those producers my agents and my mom who
will agree with you